the big issue in the Guatemalan
elections is not who's on the ballot but
who's been left off it
the Guatemalan courts have already
disqualified multiple presidential
candidates for alleged irregularities
Thelma Cabrera an indigenous leftist
leader Roberto Azu a former president's
son and most importantly Carlos Pineda
the former front-runner in the race
who could have been a thorn in the side
of Guatemala's powerful political Elite
suspicions abound that their removal was
politically motivated
we talk about democracy but we are not a
democratic country because our rights
are violated
[Applause]
a Serial campaigner and former first
lady hoping her pledges of social
programs will land her the job
10 Guatemalans are poor we will
eradicate poverty
a seasoned Diplomat and Centrist
we're going to confront corruption we're
going to invest in education and health
daughter of a former dictator who's
planning to crack down on crime
the people want the death penalty to be
applied and actually the Constitution
enshrines it we don't have to be scared
of making firm decisions
the issues crime is certainly near the
top of the list for a population
terrorized by street gangs who rob
kidnap and kill
and then there are Guatemala's perennial
problems crushing inequality Relentless
corruption and one of the worst infant
mortality rates in the region
for that list a growing authoritarian
Tendencies during this Administration
dozens of Judges prosecutors and
journalists have been forced to flee the
country or wound up in prison
for any of the kind
in the race ready and willing to change
that panorama it's unlikely the country
will find out on Sunday this election is
expected to go to a second round this
August John Holman Al Jazeera